[Music]
shocking news involving the US Postal
Service earlier today the Postal Service
announced for the first time in history
they're going to stop delivering some
types of mail on Saturdays yeah
they say this is going to save them over
two billion dollars yes I'm sorry three
other question yeah what if you're a
stalker who sends a creepy postcard to
Glenn Close every day a postcard with
the photo of your back with the name
Glenn Close shaved into it will then
still deliver that on a Saturday I'm
sorry sir they will not deliver
postcards no all right what if you're a
stalker who sends a creepy letter to
Julian and the goalies every day a
letter wherein I described what I would
do to her if we ever found ourselves in
a snow-bound cabin with nothing but a
futon three crates of whipped cream and
a jar of Nutella will they still
delivered act if it's margulies and no
not on a Saturday
all right what if you're a stalker who
sends a catalog to Annette Bening
everyday and Abercrombie and Fitch
catalog where I pasted my head on top of
all those studly young bodies with the
rock-hard abs and functioning genitalia
they will no no catalogs they won't send
catalogs now what if you're a stalker
who sends a package full of vibrators to
Diane Sawyer every day vibrators that
turn red white and blue and play the
star-spangled banner when you turn them
on will they still deliver that yes in
fact they will deliver packages
I just saw
[Applause]
that was not supposed to happen
I can't believe the one show or I
mentioned that at the top of the program
as a joke and we get that on television
[Applause]
he's unbelievable he probably works as a
plumber I know